تداويها ما اقترفته ايديها بايديها نعم
هذا هو الحال الامريكي مع اوكرانيا فها هو
مستشار الامن القومي للبيت الابيض
يعلن ان الرئيس الامريكي
حاليا وتزويدها بقدرات كبيره للدفاع الجوي
بحسب قوله فعن اي قدرات يتحدات وليس هناك
صواريخ او طائرات ليجيب الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن محاولا ارضاء كياف ولو قليلا بان
البيت الابيض قد وافق على دفعه جديده من
المساعدات العسكريه الامريكيه لاوكرانيا
والتي ستشمل المدفعيه والذخيره والاسلحه
المضاده للدبابات وفي الاسبوع المقبل سيتم
تسليم اولى دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا فهل تكفيكم هذه المساعدات ايها
الاوكران لننتقل الى خطوط التماس المشتعله
على الاوكرانيه حيث قال الجيش الاوكراني
ان دفاعاته تصدت لسته 36 صاروخ الروسيا من
اصل ثلاثه واربعين عشرون منها في هجوم على
العاصمه اصفر عن اصابه سبعه مداريين وتضرر
عدد من المباني والمنشات وتتزايد المخاوف
الاوكرانيه من ارتفاع الهجمات الروسيه على
منشات الطاقه خصوصا مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء
وها هو المصدر يتحدى سماء اوكرانيا شهدت
43 صاروخا روسيا في هجمات متواصله تقول
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه متحدثه عن اسقاط
36 منها تعرضت مقاطعه ريفني لهجوم مشابه
اصاب منشاه للطاقه على ذات السياق وبعد ان
ظل خط التماس بين الجيشين الاوكراني
والروسيه ثابتا لشهور ليرتفع الهاجس
الغربي حيظه بسبب الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
الذي لم ياتي بجديد فقد افادت صحيفه
السريد جورنا عن مصادر عسكريه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تمكنت لاول مره من اختراق الخط
الدفاعي الروسي الرئيسي في جنوب شرق
البلاد بمركبات مدرعه تقدم يعول عليه
الجيش الاوكراني للتحرك نحو بحر ازوف وقطع
طرق الامداد الروسيه لكن هل يصمت الروس
امام تقدم كهذا ان كان قد حذف حقا وفي
تطور جديد ولافت في المعارك على الجبهه
الاوكرانيه قال حاكم مدينه سوفستيبول
عاصمه شبه جزيره القرم ان القوات
الاوكرانيه شنت هجوما صاروخيا على مقر
الاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود من جانبها
اعلنت سلطات القرم وقوع ست اصابات جراء
الهجوم وطلبت من السكان تجنب الشوارع
الرئيسيه في المدينه تحسبا لوقوعه هجوم
اوكرانيا اخر وفي وقت لاحق اعلنت السلطات
اعاده افتتاح جسر القرم الذي يربط المنطقه
بالبار الروسي حظر الحركه لفتره وجيزه عقب
الهجوم لوصل الاوكران استفزاز الدب الروسي
فكيف سيكون الرد هذه المره الرد الاولي
لموسكو لم يتاخر حيث تعرضت مدينه خيراسون
الاوكرانيه لقصف روسيا المكثف فيما قتل
شخص على الاقل بعد تعرض حيا سكني في
المدينه لوبيل من القذائف الصاروخيه كما
وردت انباء تفيد بدخول مدرعات اوكرانيه
ودبابات لجنوب زابوريجيا للمره الاولى
متجاوزه الخط الدفاعيه الروسي واليكم
المصدر قال رئيس الاداره العسكريه
الاقليميه في خرسون اوليكسوندر بروكودين
ان شخصا واحدا على الاقل قتل في قصف روسيا
على المدينه الواقعه الجنوبيه اوكرانيا
واضاف روكودين ان شخصا اخر اصيب بعد ان او
بعد التعرض احياء سكنيه في خرسون قريبه من
خط المواجهه لضربات روسيه مكثفه
ما تسبب في نشوب حريق في المنطقه
فيما قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
روسيا اطلقت نحو 43 صاروخا اسقطت منها 36
وقد استهدف عشرون صاروخا للعاصمه ما اصفر
عن اصابه اشخاص عده وتضرر مباني ومنشات
مختلفه والامور لا زالت تحدث والمعارك
تزداد حده يا ساده لتعلن الدفاع الروسي
اليوم ان خسائر الجيش الاوكراني بلغت 490
جنديا خلال يوم كما دمرت القوات الروسيه
دبابتين من طراز ليوبارد المانيه على محور
كوبيانسيك والمصدر نتصفحه امامكم في
الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه ليقوم
الرئيس الاوكراني بزيارته المكوكيه للغرب
طلبا للنجده حيث وصل زيلينسكي رفقه زوجته
الى كندا في زياره غير معلنه مسبقا بعد ان
كان قد توجه الى واشنطن من نيويورك ومن
المقرر ان يلتقي زيلينسكي ورئيس
وذلك بعد ان تصاعدت حده الخلاف بين وارسو
وكيا في الايام الاخيره الماضيه بسبب
الحظر الذي فرضته بولندا على واردات
الحبوب الاوكرانيه لحمايه مزارعيها هي
ازمه متصاعده بين بولندا واوكرانيا ليعلن
رئيس الوزراء البولندي
ماتيوسكي ان وارسو اوقف التوريد الاسلحه
الى كياف مضيفا ان بلاده ستركز على تسليح
نفسها اقتصاديا قالت وكاله بلومبرج ان
روسيا
على التوالي من حصاد محصول قياسي من القمح
الامر الذي يعزز مكانتها الرائده في السوق
العالميه للمصدر الحبوب لتصبح صادرات
المواد الغذائيه بالنسبه لروسيا المصدر
الرئيسي للدخل المالي بعد النفط من جهه
اخرى وبحسب وكاله ستاندر اند بورس فانه من
المتوقع ان تصبح منطقه الشرق الاوسط
المصدرا رئيسيا لامداد المنتجات النفطيه
الى اوروبا وذلك بعد ان تقرر ان تقضي
اوروبا اول الشتاء لها على الاطلاق بدون
الديزل الروسي وفيلم منطقه ذاتها ولكن في
حرب اخرى لم تكد تشتعل حتى انطفات شرارتها
حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
التشكيلات المسلحه في قرباغ سلمت سته
مدرعات واكثر من 800 سلاح فردي ومضاد
للدبابات وحوالي خمسه الاف قطعه ذخيره حتى
الثاني والعشرين من سبتمبر ومن الحروب
التقليديه الى المعارك النوويه حيث اظهرت
صور الاقمار الصناعيه بان ثلاث دول كبرى
تفعل نشاطا نوويا تحت الارض واوضحت الصور
ان روسيا والولايات المتحده والصين تقوم
ببناء منشات جديده وحفرت انفاقا جديده في
مواقع تجاربها النوويه في السنوات الاخيره
في وقت تصاعدت فيه التوترات بين القوى
النوويه الثلاثه الكبرى الى اعلى
مستوياتها منذ عقود وتو ضح صور بحسب خبراء
التوسعات الاخيره في ثلاثه مواقع للتجارب
النوويه مقارنه بعدد قليل فقط من المواقع
قبل السنان مضت والعالم يقترب من الكارثه
الاحداث والتطورات
[موسيقى]
صواريخ باليستيه وطائره مسيره واسلحه
استراتيجيه للمره الاولى والاف الجنود
وذلك في استعراض قوه للحوثيين في العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء ياتي ذلك في خطاب مفاوضات
مع السعوديه لانهاء النزاع الدم في البلد
الغارق في الحرب وعلى وقع قرع الطبول
والموسيقى سار الاف المقاتلين في ميدان
السبعين تحت انظار كبار قاده الحوثيين
وقدم الحوثيون خلال العرض مدرعات محليه
الصنع وزوارق محمله برشاشات وصواريخ
وطائرات من دون طيار فيما كان الثلاث
مروحيات عسكريه تحلق في الاعلى وفي بيان
للحوثيين قالوا فيه انهم جاهزون لخوض
المعارك دفاعا عن الوطن والشعب في حال لم
يلتزم العدوان بمتطلبات السلام المشرف وفق
بيانهم اعلن الرئيس التركي رجبتايب
اردوغان عزم بلاده اتخ
اذ خطوه عن طبالور اراده البلدين من اجل
تشغيل شبكات للطاقه نحو اوروبا مرورا عبر
تركيا
[موسيقى]